employers across the country are
beginning to reopen their offices as
many americans transition
back to in-person work work work new
data from linkedin shows the fastest
growing priority for workers
is job flexibility being able to work
from anywhere
at any time 55 percent of millennials
support this option for
work and linkedin also found that nearly
one in 10 job postings
now allow remote work compare that to 1
in 50 last year
we asked our viewers on social media
what they think and some told us they
need more structure
while others said working from home was
less stressful and more productive
joining us now is caroline fairchild at
large for linkedin news
welcome welcome tony good to see you in
person you've been parading around eight
months remote
is that what i have i have i've been
working remote for eight months and
actually this is my first
in-person work with my colleagues i
actually
wrote on wow we're honored we are
honored before the pandemic i wrote on
instagram that i would love to go to
work with gayle king every single day
and then a week later the pandemic hit
and i didn't go to work with anyone and
now i'm back with you guys
uh so the pandemic has to change
people's relationship to work in a
million different ways like what are the
most important
from where you're sitting it's it's
flexibility is number one we're seeing
from over 50
of workers that they want flexibility in
their job and what that means is i think
a lot of people think about flexibility
and think about location first
but we're actually hearing from workers
that they want flexibility of the time
that they're working
so it's not necessarily i want to go
into the office or i want to work from
home it's
let me do my job on my own time i'm an
adult and so that's what we're seeing is
people not necessarily thinking about
work from home or work work remotely but
they want to think about
job more flexibly in terms of when
they're getting their work done well as
people try to make that decision
caroline don't people who are back in
the office
have the upper hand because i think you
need face-to-face interaction with the
powers that be
in order to advance you know yeah i
think that's definitely a concern and
we're seeing a lot of people at linkedin
right now hesitant to return to the
office you know they have some health
concerns
they're nervous to be interacting with
people in person at this point in the
pandemic
but we are seeing companies really step
and up and think more equitably around
how they're treating workers whether
they're at home or they're in the office
and this comes down to individual
managers you just need to make sure that
there isn't that home court advantage if
you will if you are going back into the
office
but americans are also quitting their
jobs in record numbers what's happening
we're calling it the great resignation
we're seeing right now 40 percent of
employers upwards of 40 percent of
people are thinking about quitting their
jobs right now and
you know anthony why i think the
pandemic as tony just said
made us re-examine everything about our
lives and if you think about
pre-pandemic
jobs was a big part of everyone's life
and now people are saying i don't know
how big i wanted to be a part of my life
now but one theory is that pre-pandemic
you liked the office you liked lunch you
liked your friends at work you liked
your commute you liked your quiet time
now you're left with none of that and
just the work itself and you're
realizing
i don't like this work this is not fun
exactly if you think about like the
perks of going back into the office
before the pandemic started for
knowledge workers it was all about the
free lunch or the ping pong tables or
being able to go to happy hours
i think we're still the point right now
where those perks aren't back and so yes
a lot of people are saying
can i continue to work from home and the
reality is you know
there's a huge talent shortage right now
so if you are a valuable employee 70 of
companies are telling us they're having
a hard time attracting talent finding
the right talent so employees have upper
hand what are companies doing what are
companies doing to respond to this well
they have to do a lot they have to do it
very quickly because 70 of companies are
saying that they're having a hard time
finding talent and you have all these
people trying to quit work and so
they're responding by
a lot of things number one is providing
this flexibility if you're
at a place that doesn't have flexible
options there are a lot of places that
are offering it
the other is mental health i think that
mental health is now considered the
fourth
pillar of benefits right very
interesting and so it was something that
wasn't offered before but now after
we've seen the pandemic
after everyone's been working from home
and seeing their whole lives employers
can't ignore the fact that their
employees are not robots
and they have a bunch of stuff going on
outside of work this is particularly
important for working parents
and doesn't give employees a better an
upper hand during these times
absolutely i think if you performed well
during the pandemic you continue to
perform well you continue to have this
upper hand because like i said so many
employers are having a hard time
finding talent and you still love your
job i still love my job tony so i'm not
being pretty
unless gayle wants to hire me i work for
gayle but other than that i'm not
quitting anything welcome back to
in-person work i want to hang out with
you carol
i still like my job too thank you good
to see you